We begin
with an
urgent search
and rescue operation
that is currently underway
in the Atlantic Ocean.
Right now, U.S.
Coast Guard officials
are racing to find a submersible
operated by a company that runs tours
of the Titanic wreckage.
Officials say that this was reported
overdue on Sunday
and is said to have only 96 hours
of survival time.
We are told several government
agencies and deep companies
are working on reestablishing contact
with this submersible.
CNN's Miguel
Marquez is joining us
now live with more details
on this Miguel.
What do you know at this point?
You know, the company
that runs this operation, Ocean
Gate Expeditions, does everything from,
you know, science underwater
to photography and video
to tourism as well,
to places like the Titanic wreckage
and have done it for quite some time.
It costs about $250,000
per person to do this.
What we don't know
is exactly who was on this submersible.
It can hold
if it is the one
that they have up on their website,
it can hold up to five people.
It has 96 hours worth of air.
But it all depends on
how many people are on that submersible
and how deep it is.
We know that the U.S.
Coast Guard, along with Canadian
Air Force as well, is assisting in this.
They're all moving to this area
by fixed wing and boats
trying to get to the area
so that they can help out.
But look, this is extremely remote.
These depths are incredibly deep.
The Titanic itself is about 3800 meter.
That's about 13,000
feet under the under
the ocean,
just extreme, extreme, remote
and difficult place
to operate on a good day.
The Canadians do have a P-8
or a Poseidon aircraft
that does have some ability
to see basically underwater
as a sub hunting
aircraft
that can see underwater to some degree.
But it's not clear
if they know where this this craft is
and and what exactly happened to it.
As you mentioned,
they have about 96 hours of air
in sort of a perfect conditions,
but it's not clear
given that this was reported
missing 24 hours ago now,
how much more air they might have
and where this search goes from now.
Right now
all hands on deck
trying to find this craft Brianna.
All right, Miguel,
thank you for the very latest there.
I want to turn now to an expert on this.
We have Butch Hendrick here with us.
Butch,
you have 30 years of experience
as a rescue diver.
You're also the president
and founder of Lifeguard Systems,
which is an international rescue
and recovery training company.
Do you know where you begin
with a rescue like this?
Well, I think the same
way the United States
Coast Guard
and the Canadians will be working.
The first thing is to discover, does
the unit submersible have releasable
beacons, emergency beacons?
So if it does, then
it would have
possibly released a beacon
or to to the surface
so that it could be tracked.
A signal would be coming out off of that.
The Coast Guard, the Canadians,
the bridge would be able to pick up
and then be able to start to track
where it might have come from.
We'd be looking at
what has happened
in the last 48 hours to the weather
what conditions may have changed
that are not normal.
What would have happened
with the currents
at the depths
and in
between the bottom at 12,000 plus feet
and the surface could occur
and have suddenly taken in over
overrode
the power of the unit submersible.
That's down next would be that a proper
submersible should have a beacon or two
that would be attached to it.
They could be sending out
an underwater signal
that would tell people how to find it.
So they'll be
looking for those
looking at the weather and tracking on
what would have happened to
if it got taken off of the site.
The Coast Guard
will certainly be doing
something very similar
and they'll be coming in with
their own trackers
if they find this beacon
that was released from the submersible,
they would see where it was tracked
the whether put
another one of their own in the water
and track it
and see how it would go
and where the possibilities would be.
I know that
listening to one of the admirals,
the Coast Guard is coming in
with their lower
end, shallower
water side scan sonar units at the moment
with larger, more capable
pieces of equipment behind it.
And using side
scan based on the debris field.
You'd have to have
a beautiful
mapping sequence of the entire wreck.
It could be a layover, if you will.
We would be
laying one on top of the other
in order to see what's new,
what is there that we didn't see before.
The potential's
one that the unit has
not had the power to maintain
with the current.
More likely, based on the original videos
and images of things that Bob Ballard did
with the Titanic
is that is maybe quite on something.
And I mean, these are huge concerns,
which obviously
So we do appreciate your time as we have
so many unanswered questions
at this point and quite
frankly, are trying
to get some more details
about those who are engaged
in the rescue here. Butch Hendrick.
Thank you very much
for taking the time with us
this afternoon. We do appreciate it.